He youtubers it's Charlie everybody was freaking out after the flash episode one started dropping
Yesterday about the new Flash costume as well as Barry's costumes, so I'll explain what's going on
It's not quite what everyone thinks
I wasn't expecting on doing a new flash video this soon
But because people went so crazy after Iris and Wally
Started posting from this set I figured it'd be good just to get it out of the way
So I'll do a new round of the flash Ring Giveaway -
In what I'm going to do is change the giveaway just a little bit
Just because it seems like there's a little confusion so I'll explain that at the end of the video
We back, Weback
But the important thing kid flash's costume, and I'll talk about Barry's costume in this Tube
But the big thing is the qingyan lines dale the actor that plays Wally west was posting on Instagram
Along with candice patton because apparently they were the first people shooting on the first day now
We know Danielle panabaker was there too, so she might have been filming separately in her killer frost makeup
And they didn't want her to appear on camera
Just because it might have been spoilery more on that - because the flash production office the tweeted that picture of the title also just
Deleted their Twitter account
So they got a big freaking trouble for posting that
but in a bunch of separate posts qingyun Lyons vale was posting pictures of his costume and
People took this to mean that he was wearing the red flash costume
So if you don't read the comics there have been two different times that Wally west has worn a red flash costume
It was back during the Modern age when Barry allen died he started wearing the Barry Allen
Version of the costume then during Jeff Jones run when he brought Barry allen back
They changed his costume a little bit, but it was still red. So it was a red costume, Wally west then again
They just brought back ginger
Wally West during DC rebirth, and he was wearing his yellow costume
He went off to the titans comic book and started wearing a red version of the yellow costume with his hair sticking out the top
So because we're doing flash rebirth a lot of people were like wait a minute now that
Wally's kind of the main version of the Flash wall Barry's away
does that mean they're doing the comic book thing where he takes up the mantle and the red costume at the same time because
Technically he is the main version of the flash the problem with this though. Is that kid flash's costume legs have always been red
It's always been solid yellow on red. So when you're looking at the costume below the waist. There's nothing that's different
They have changed his costume
But all they've done is made it more
Form-fitting like the way they change Barry's costume during the course of season one he had sort of a Batman problem
So during the Batman Christopher Nolan movies Batman wanted to be able to turn his head so they had to make a more
Modular version of the costume so depending on what kind of scene
They're filming crank us that has three different versions of the flash costume, so it's the same thing with Wally's costume
so even Beyond the cosmetic changes
Which is what most people talk about when they talk about new costumes like what is it going to look like they also make functional?
Updates, and I don't think that it was necessary
But candice patton came back and replied to this post when people were freaking out saying that
Wally's costume has always been read like this there was an interview
The kid flash did earlier this year that I think a lot of people missed where he talks about?
Potentially wearing a barry version of the costume where he says it's not something that's on my radar. I feel as though
There's so much story to tell and Wally has so much growing to do I'd like to see that journey continue
That's what I think is important
We need to see how these characters realistically get to where they're headed for
He's basically saying that he's not going to be wearing the red costume. He's still got a long way to go
There's a lot of character development it also makes it sound like he's not going anywhere anytime soon for a little while
I thought that it might be possible that he would go on titans eventually, but it sounds like if that's going to happen
It's not going to happen till season five of the flash or much later down the road
but the Barry allen
Costume people are like is he going to come back from the speed Force with the new version of the costume so in the grand
Tradition of the flash yes, the costume changes a little bit every year
but I feel like people are thinking a little further ahead than the show is like they want him to be wearing the
2024 version of his costume that was the one with the extra gold belt with all the highlights it did look brighter
There was some more flair on it, but I wasn't the hugest fan of it. I feel like there are better improvements
They can make with the color tone and the highlights that aren't quite as gaudy is like all that extra gold on him I felt
Like they could have done a much better job with that future flash costume
They always take inspiration from things they see in the future like saw a vision of the white emblem
So he's like you know what we should do that. That's really cool, and it became the self-fulfilling prophecy our City's very own scarlet speedster
disappeared in an explosion of life
I have to say I'm really digging the brighter red suit and the white on the symbol. Let's go wait a second
Suppose we now change the color on your suit will it be because we got the idea from this picture
That would mean we're living in a causal nexus wow. This is so trippy
So with these wearing the costume when he does come back from the speed Force
it's mostly going to look like the old version of the costume until
Cisco literally builds a new one the biggest change to his costume
I think will be the flash ring so a lot of people have asked why haven't they done the flash ring yet?
Well one it's because the rings are mostly associated with marriage
They've been building towards the Barry Iris marriage
So I think you can chart the timeline of barry using the flash ring with whatever wedding
They end up happening on the show whenever they decide to do that that could be at the end of this season that could be
at the beginning of next season
But it just makes sense that if they're going to get married there's going to be a wedding ring that
Ring would be the flash ring, and that's when he would start using it more nobody's been talking about it
But I think the other big reason why they haven't used the flash ring yet is because it requires
Liberal special effects and that would cost them a lot more money
This is Gonna be fun
It's a lot cheaper
For them to just turn the camera around and have barry be in the costume like it's really cool
Watching Savitur climb out of that costume, but it's really expensive and it blows a lot of time
So they do it a couple times
And then they find really quick ways to just jump over that in the future
So they have the technology they can totally do the flash ring now
I think they're just holding back because of the wedding and
because it's kind of
Expensive to do it in every single episode and in the comics barry doesn't even use the flash ring that much anymore
The ginger Wally west makes fun of him because he can actually use the speed force to manifest his costume
He doesn't even need a ring to do it anymore
He literally just wills it into existence, so I think the show at some point will learn to do that, too
But it's one of those advanced abilities that they tend to hold off till later seasons
So when you're thinking about new flash costume just think just extra bright highlights like color change, but other than that
I don't think it's going to change that much and just to clarify the flash ring giveaway
I probably don't do this enough what I do is I pick the winner randomly from the comments when I say leave a comment
It's not a comment about winning the flash ring. It's just meant to be a comment about the flash TV show in general
I'll just remind everyone about that before the season 4 episode video start
But what's going to happen?
is there'll be some new Spider-Man coming up new game of thrones new Rick and morty leave all your
Requests in the comments below you can click here to learn more about?
Episode 1 and you can click here for brand new Rick and morty thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight